hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Judith who wrote
in asking about how to start up a
business without a lot of money so she
wrote in saying dear I'm going to have a
question for you is it possible for
someone to start a business with very
little capital or no capital at all and
grow I'm looking at a cosmetic business
I want to try this business but the
challenging part here is it's so
competitive regards Judith so Judith it
is absolutely possible to start a
business no capital or almost no capital
if you look at any famous entrepreneur
almost they started with almost nothing
if you look at any of the profiles on my
web site of the famous entrepreneurs
brand name people that you know they
started with just an idea very little
capital and we build up their business
so don't think you have to have big
investors venture capital angel
investors on board or a huge loan from
the bank you'll start your business most
people start with nothing just hard work
sweat equity grinding it out until they
become successful so to make it happen a
couple of ideas for you don't start
spending money until you're making money
so try to figure out ways to start your
business on a smaller scale we still
have may have a big vision for where you
want to go but you start on a smaller
scale without spending a lot of money so
you can start part-time if you need to
start a service-based type of business
instead of having a product don't invest
in any major equipment that you don't
absolutely need start out of your home
so if you're doing a cosmetic business
start something out of your home start
something that a service base and start
with something that you don't have to
invest a lot of money into and start
getting known for excellent service and
excellent quality on maybe one specific
thing so you might not be able to
compete with everything and you're up
against bigger more established players
but try to find one thing that you could
be known as the best act and really
focus in on that provide amazing awesome
service that people want to keep coming
back for that
other friends about and that's a good
way to start as you start building up a
little bit of capital money is coming in
then you can look at expanding your
services potentially get in a retail
space or an office space find more
equipment and that's how you can grow
but you start by keeping things really
low cost service space don't invest a
lot of money invest your time and energy
into providing an amazing service
getting that momentum and word-of-mouth
marketing happening for your business
and eventually be able to grow it up so
I hope that helps if you guys like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and I've also love to hear your feedback
and suggestions if you want to comment
under this video and stay tuned for the
next episode
you